[Applause]
[Music]
you don't seem surprised to see me I'm
not this isn't a social call Rucker I'm
here to take you
in my people and I will resist you
innocent people died in that bombing
today the augmented our suffering the
genocide it begins with demonizing us
treating us as less than human exiling
us so we are forgotten and then
Exterminating us you get him pissed
enough to end this guy yet I got a no
Kill Order who have thought he'd done
enough to Warrant extreme
prejudice how dare you speak to me of
peace and fairness on behalf of Masters
Who hide in the shadows and murdering
without the courage to Proclaim their
convictions in front of the rest of the
[Music]
world I suspect there's a power struggle
Brewing within our
organization some people inside Ark are
less committed to our
ideals then help me find
them somewhere down there hiding in
plain sight is your real
terrorist
I can only fight enemies I
see then isn't it time you brought them
into the
light